has arrived in China he's visiting the
country for the first time in nearly 20
years we're going to speak to Katrina
you who's live for us in Beijing what
more do we know about this visit
well the U.S and its allies may have
shunned Assad but China on Thursday
rolled out the red carpet as he and his
wife touched down to the Eastern Chinese
city of Hangzhou now over the next few
days he's expected to meet president Xi
Jinping and he will also attend the
opening of the Hangzhou Asian Games on
Saturday now Assad did visit China back
in 2004 when he met then a former
Chinese leader who Jintao but this is
his first state visit to the country
since war broke out almost 12 years ago
there so it really does seem that this
visit marks the end of Syria's
diplomatic isolation China is one of the
few countries that Assad has visited in
over the past few years and it has to be
noted that Beijing has been a staunch
supporter of Damascus since the war
broke out it blocked in the UN the
resolution to sanction Assad although
Western sanctions did go ahead there it
also blocked a move to create an
independent body that would assess
what's happened to the thousands of
people that have disappeared during the
Syrian conflict something Beijing said
would interfere with damascus's
sovereignty now Beijing has also
promised Syria that it wants to help in
its economic reconstruction and its Aid
and the rebuilding of infrastructure and
expected that that will be the topic
that will dominate Assad's conversations
while he's speaking to officials here
yeah can you imagine the kind of PR
value this must be giving president
Bashar al-assad and Syria as well but it
is as you're saying it comes coming at a
time when China is expanding its
influence in the Middle East generally
and the significance of it being
interested in Syria shouldn't be
underestimated
that's right so Assad will be looking to
boost his legitimacy as a leader when
he's meeting with President Xi Jinping
in China for its part wants to boost its
own legitimacy as a power player in the
Middle Eastern region at a time when the
U.S and its presence is declining in
that region we saw in March China
brokered a surprise deal between Saudi
Arabia and Iran and June Beijing
welcomed Palestinian leader Mahmoud
Abbas and Beijing proposed its own peace
plan between Israel and Palestine and
when we saw just last month during the
brics summit gathering uh Summit and
that is dominated by Beijing that the
grouping welcomed Saudi Arabia Iran and
the UAE among its members so Beijing is
really looking to expand its reach in
the Middle East and not only that I
think it's also looking to set itself
apart as a different kind of
international leader compared to the
United United States certainly Assad is
not the only leader that has been
ostracized by the West that has been
fated by Beijing in comparison this year
it's also welcome vladway Putin from
Russia Venezuela's Maduro and also
Iran's Ibrahim raisi Katrina thank you
very much indeed Katrina you talking to
us from Beijing